good morning John today I want to talk
about saying stuff wrong it is as far as
I'm concerned the most embarrassing
thing that can happen and unfortunately
just like when your fly's down sometimes
people are embarrassed about telling you
about it and so you go on and on with
this intellectual fly down your
underwear exposed toilet paper hanging
out of the back of your pants number one
you couldn't care less if you could care
less than you do care number two for all
intents and purposes I don't know what
intensive purposes are but that's not
what you mean three you do not hold down
the fort because the fort isn't
inflatable and filled with helium you
hold the fort it's a military metaphor
five this is Frankenstein no this is
Frankenstein that guy is Frankenstein's
monster six deer Elam's Morissette when
you get a death-row pardon two minutes
too late that is extremely unfortunate
it is not however ironic and finally
number seven if you're saying an acronym
make sure that the thing you see after
the acronym isn't in the acronym like
when you put your pin number in an ATM
machine of course implying that you're
putting your personal identification
number number into the automated teller
machine machine but I also want to note
here that it's totally okay to say the
La Brea Tar Pits despite the fact that
when you translate that out it's the
tartar pits
let's take a common comment on
vlogbrothers videos you lose the game
except it is often spelled like this and
in that case I don't lose the game
because I'm not thinking about the game
I'm thinking about the failure of the
American education system moving on to
the mother country the United Kingdom
which is the United Kingdom of Northern
Ireland and Great Britain Great Britain
is an island that contains three
autonomous owl countries the countries
of Wales Scotland and England if you're
in a pub in Wales and you say gee guys I
sure love it here in England they will
punch you in the face England is not a
synonym for the United Kingdom now we're
moving on to the two most confusing
words in the English language as far as
I'm concerned effect and effect of
course not pronounced effect and effect
the pronounced effect and effect but I
remember it this way the greenhouse
effect
effects the climate effects almost
always being a noun and affect almost
always being a verb but this is extra
super confusing because sometimes affect
is a verb too so it is literally okay to
say I effected the effect that verb
effect means to bring about an effect so
if you say I effected the effect you
mean I brought about the effect if you
say I effected the effect that means
that you changed the effect so if you
are good at bringing about effect you
are effective sorry this is horribly
confusing it just is but it's important
to figure it out now to finish this off
I'm gonna talk about some
mispronunciation because when I was in
college I did a long oral report on Leon
Battista Alberti in which I discussed at
length all of the facades he designed in
Renaissance Italy except instead of
saying facade I said acade and it was
one of the most embarrassing moments of
my life when I found out okay let's go
it's not Ari it's arrived its epitome
not epitome Edinburgh
not Edinburgh not ether real but
ethereal not me me but meme not a fez
'red but haphazard facetious not face
giuse not the sequel to the Superbowl
the hyperbole but in fact hyperbole
colonel despite the fact that this word
has no R in it
boolean not boo lean and dishevelled not
disabled and that is all I've got for
you I hope that I have at least a little
bit help the world avoid some
embarrassment
nerdfighteria in the comments below help
me feel better about my facade mistake
and tell me some word that you've
mispronounced in public before John I'll
see you on Wednesday